les repas sur blake ont la cote la bonne
vieille plaque à biscuits sont
maintenant à cuire légumes viandes et
poissons
on y dépose les ingrédients on met au
four et le tour est joué
aujourd'hui on voit des plaques sont
vraiment beaucoup plus solide beaucoup
plus costaude qui se déforme pas avec
des enduits a fait les enduits entre six
à dix ils sont vraiment nombreux est
différent aujourd'hui
l'épicerie propose un banc d'essai de
8,2 si claque dans nos tests on en aura
quatre dollars
la moyenne est autour de 25 28 $ pour
une plaque de qualité et puis on a testé
aussi une plaque en fonte qui était à 55
2 en plus du facteur prix
nous avons sélectionné les plaques selon
la disponibilité les caractéristiques de
fabrication ainsi que des matériaux
utilisés
les plaques retenu pour notre banc
d'essai sont betty crocker une marque
son nom en hélium gotham still waiting
gournay chase ricardo oxo good reads pro
cuisine art mineur alors là on ne nomme
huit spécimens qui visuellement ça
semble quand même y en a qui se
ressemblent beaucoup
la dimension et stores d'or c'est léger
ça c'est ce même mois
c'est très léger très mou cet art très
bien reçus au quai à l'antenne on
imagine que ça ça peut changer de forme
rapidement
mais même à court terme ont su dans les
faits de torsion que subissent certaines
plaques lorsqu'ils sont chauffés créer
une pente ce qui provoque une cuisson
inégale on voit ici que le jus serment
écoulée donc ce qui restait de jus au
brûlé puis dans le coin inférieur ou le
jus s'est accumulée bien lors on a plein
de jus avec des légumes puis du poulet
qui sont plus bouillie que grillé ce
sont les plaques moins épaisse qui ont
le plus réagi à la chaleur c'est celle
dont la tôle est la plus mince mais déjà
au poids est ce cas on arrête différence
avec m de salles
non ici la cuisine a requis trois fois
plus présent que celle là elle se
démarque définitivement par l'épaisseur
du fond c'est celle qui est loin le plus
épais les autres ici ont des épaisseurs
à 6 comparé à seyssel enfants que la wii
donc c'est enfoncer définitivement plus
dépaysé beaucoup plus l'eau douce y est
beaucoup plus petit aussi pour une
famille de quatre un peu petit ce que je
me suis rendu compte que pour pour faire
des repas à la plaque ça fonctionne bien
mais pour la pâtisserie c'est moins
recommandées il a fallu que je me dis
bah aussi sur les parois parce que la
paix est que coller sur les comptes
ainsi la plaque en aluminium est très
répandue dans l'industrie de la
restauration ayant boulangerie mais à 7
$ et les plus minces et ne possède pas
un enduit antiadhésif la plaque
oxo possède un fond textures et qui est
formée de petites pyramides à la longue
le revêtement pourrait s'éroder
[Musique]
sûr que si j'ai de la sauce qui brûle
dans le creux un peu plus difficile la
vie quels sont les critères à
privilégier lors de l'achat d'une de ces
plaques l'acier me semble le meilleur
matériau pour la fabrication d'une
plaque de cuisson mon avis les passeurs
font de la plaque est beaucoup plus
important que le mélange métallurgique
en fin de compte qui est dans l'acier la
construction du rebord nous indique si
la plaque va être déformés au four si
vraiment la cie et repli plusieurs fois
autour d'elle pour former un camp très
très rigide
c'est définitivement plus contrairement
à d'autres plaques ou son jeu sa peine
écrasez afin de vérifier l'uniformité de
la coloration et l'adhérence à la
surface de la plaque
nous avons fui de recettes sur chacune
d'elles
la première est un pancake donc là on a
un aperçu de ce que ça peut donner comme
comme différence là d'une plaque à la
world tonnes au début pour tout les
poseurs de 15 me tenait vraiment foncer
mais définitivement que celle là la
coloration vaut beaucoup plus rapidement
comme la plaque d'aluminium et luisante
et qu'elle réfléchisse la chaleur par
rayonnement la cuisson a été plus lente
on a vraiment un produit qui est
beaucoup plus par ici
deux de ces produits sont vraiment
comparable en termes de dimensions et
d'apparence et les résultats sont
similaires
j'ai écrit plusieurs fois la même pâte
avec les mêmes ingrédients même faut en
même temps père as-tu toujours pareil
des fois ricardo et meilleur des fois
cuisinant les meilleurs donc les deux
des variances un petit peu mais vraiment
elle performe les deux de façon égale la
deuxième recette s'inscrit dans la
tendance des repas la plaque
frédéric à préparer un poulet ou légumes
pour avoir de bons résultats lors des
essais il s'est assuré que son four
était bien de niveau et il a bien
réparti des aliments sur la plaque en
évitant les superposer parce qu'il
donnait une belle coloration et que la
sauce et sirupeuse frédéric a donné la
note presque parfaite à deux de ces
plaques la cuisine ans et la garde au
père forme quand même très bien pour la
cuisson des repas comme ça sauf que je
dirais que dans l'arrêt cardio la
coloration a été un peu plus égales que
dans la cuisine c'est définitivement mes
deux préférés
[Musique]